all right George
yes George uh where are you from
originally where'd you grow up
um I was born in New York City but I was
raised in Springfield Massachusetts
was your family like growing up
um discombobulated I mean I grew up in a
rough household
um
it was a lot of
violence growing up my stepfather used
to beat my mother bad
beat me
for the most dumbest things in the world
um
it was very scary to live at home
and my mom
she never did anything to protect us but
I know she loved us but
she's there she did her best you know
what kind of kid were you in high school
um say it again what kind of kid were
you in high school
um through school
I was doing good until
I hit when I was 10 years old something
happened where
I just started doing real bad I was real
gifted drawing
I was getting straight A's but after
that I was getting suspended from school
from hitting the principal down to
beating up kids and you know what I mean
I was real messed up
at that age you know uh
my stepfather really did a number on me
did you have something you want to do
with your life after After High School
um I actually wanted to be a fireman
but
that's all shot the hell I mean I picked
up too way too many cases
um
it's just even right now as I speak I I
I can't even foresee if a good future
for myself right now it is I'm 45 years
old I got 23 years in prison
and they say they don't judge you for in
your past but they they do when I go for
a job interview they they shoot me down
fast
and I'm I resort to doing things that
that I considered beneath me but I do it
because I need to eat you know what I
mean so I resort to boosting to stealing
and at the same time I try to hide it
from other people in my life that that I
don't do that but
I actually
that's what I do
and stuff I don't want to do I really
don't want to do it but
is your biggest problem the violence in
the prison
I think it's the lack of belief or is it
drugs
I mean drugs got to play in it but I
think it's
honestly is that I don't I can't I don't
believe in myself at all they beat that
out of me man
a lot of a lot of my friends would tell
me hey man you know you fish with
something great man boom boom but I
when I hear those words I I think it's
[__]
because
I've never been handed something good
and a lot of it is my fault I understand
you know what I mean because I feed into
the crap you know what I mean like just
but it's hard man
it's hard believing in yourself when you
come from a childhood like that yeah you
know what I mean and
a lot of mixed messages you know I mean
my stuff out used to take me out
stealing but tell me not to steal you
know what I mean
a lot of things like that in
bitter but
even to this day
when I got out of prison I was so happy
everything I thought I had all the
chances
on my side but nothing
I still feel like I'm in prison
you know what I mean so
it's being in prison easier than being
out in the streets yes because
everything is decided for me
you know I mean they give you a schedule
you know what I mean you got to go to
school you got to go to work and you got
to come back to your cell everything is
decided for you so the stresses off you
you know what I mean and it's sad to say
that
that was more at peace in there than out
here because out here I'm on my own I
have to do everything myself
and it's hard man my girl's getting on
me you know what I mean she's like you
got to do something and I try to explain
to her like I'm trying man but I can't
do nothing and I feel bad for myself
because I don't feel like a man
you know what I mean I gotta help around
and
all I could do is chump change from
[__] stealing doing
things I I don't want her to know about
you know what I mean I mean she's smart
you know she she knows what I
but I do sometimes
when did you come to Los Angeles
I came to Los Angeles about
I got out of prison I'm doing 10 years
in Massachusetts
and
I went to live out in um Cape Cod
Hyannis
I met a girl and I got a job and
everything out there I was doing all
right until I got started doing drugs
again I started doing uh cocaine
weed drinking and
she decided to come up here to
California I was on young man mind you I
was only out six months from doing a 10
year
and I came out here and I got caught out
here and they gave me 13 years
and I did the whole 13 out here
so I just got out like
nine years ago eight nine years ago
so you've been on the streets I've been
on the streets
I lived over in and out with some girls
you know I mean that I meet
but
even when I meet a girl I kind of like
push back because
I fear that they're gonna
I don't like see the real me
you know I mean like they see I know
they I know I stayed clean I take
showers they think that I'm not homeless
but you know eventually I tell them like
you know I am kind of homeless and I
start living with them but then I can't
pull my own
and that's what
you know I lost a lot of good girls like
that man
and this one is hanging by a thread too
you know what I mean
she's a good girl man but would you
blame drugs is the problem or do you
blame the self-worth that is lacking
from your childhood abuse I blame that
because I stopped doing drugs before
I stopped doing fatty I stopped doing
crystal meth I stopped it and it didn't
do nothing to me honestly then I didn't
go to withdrawals or nothing I don't do
it like these guys when they do drugs
they give themselves to the drug to the
drug that's what they live for I don't
live for that you know what I mean I
mean I do it as a
moves a mood stabilizer or whatever you
want to call it you know what I mean
makes me feel good for the moment but I
try not to be like nodding off I'm doing
yeah I just do enough to get through the
day
you know feel nice and that's it you
know what I mean but
and I've been doing good doing that you
know what I mean I don't let myself get
too
I don't sell myself for the drug you
know what I mean I always try to at
least have something left in my pocket
to eat to get dressed
to give something to my girl you know
what I mean something like that are you
making money boosting boosting or going
to clothing stores and steel and then I
bring it down this way
and then I take orders and like people
will tell me hey I need this this this
this for my house I need a vacuum
cleaner you know what I mean it's stupid
stuff like that but I bring it for them
they give me chunk change for you I mean
you know what I mean but it's something
sometimes they'll pay me in drugs
and then I'll try to take the drugs and
flip it as much as I can but I really I
end up doing most of it
it's kind of like
this is like I'm driving myself into the
ground man but
yeah Aldi I'm 45 years old 45.
kids no kids no kids and I'm happy for
that um because I don't want my to be in
this position and have a kid
I don't want I never want to put a kid
to do something like that
you've been in love before
yeah I've been in love before
did the low self-worth kind of get in
the way of that too yeah the jealousy
the
the belief that this girl cannot love me
this the way she says she does you know
what I mean that's got to be [__]
you know I mean that's what I say to
myself this girl really loves me like
that that's gotta be [__] you know
what I mean like because I never had
nobody love me like that
so someone to be like they sold for me
I'm like
I always question that you know what I
mean
and then I end up being the sabotager
you know I mean I end up messing the
relationship up and
but yeah
it's like having a dark cloud over your
head everything you do gets colored by
that
and I know it's me you know me I try to
before I try to blame it on other people
and everything like that but it is me
it's
it's the way I think of myself if I
think of myself a certain way and I'm
walking around people that attribute
that certain way
but it's hard to be to to pretend to be
happy let's say walk through life being
happy and just you know smile more it's
hard to do that down here
just the other day look
got stabbed
oh Jesus just for because I wanted to
get into the building
to go see my friend
and the dude's not even a uh what you
want to go or would you want to call it
a um a security guard oh sorry he's not
even a security guard and he just
he didn't know he stabbed me though
and I didn't know he stabbed me because
I thought I thought it actually bounced
off my shirt and I was like dude you
can't even stabbed well what the hell is
wrong with you so I walked home and when
I took off my shirt my girl was
screaming she was like what the hell I
had blood everywhere you didn't feel it
but these people out there down here man
it's just
I even feel like that's inevitable
before something fatal happens to me you
know
it's depressing yeah
that's the reason I use drugs I mean
drugs and based the only uh
it's the only Escape sometimes man you
know and then I if I leave drugs the
hell is going to replace that you know I
gotta find something that makes me feel
as good as that
that's and I can try to see any
therapist
um
um in prison
and only because they schedule for you
for one you know what I mean
but out here
you know never tried
it might be a good idea I never know
do you have siblings
yes I got um I'm the middle
child my I got my older sister Mike day
me and my little sister maira or your
sisters
um my big sister is a severe heroin
addict
my mother is a severe headboard addict
um
they just stopped after going to rehab
like
30 times
but they're doing good my little sister
is the only one that's been doing good
ever since
I fell into prison she's been she's a
Christian she married a Christian man
has a lot of kids and he's doing great
maybe there's hope for you giving that
your mom and your your older sister
got free yeah they try to make me stay
when I was in Massachusetts but I'm on
my way up here
they want they wanted me to stay with
them but
they were doing heroin in front of me
and I didn't want to do that I didn't
especially with my mom I was like I
gotta get the hell out of here man so I
just left them
they knew they understood I didn't want
to be around that stuff you know I mean
I was trying my best to do good at that
point
but it's I mean
I just got I just think I got a bad luck
I just kicked myself in the ass and I
just started doing stupid [__]
you had your life to live all over again
would you have done anything differently
oh [__] yes
man if I knew
that having
like a jacket the way I have like too
many crimes the way I do that would
affect me like this
I would stop immediately man if I knew
like that I when I was doing crying back
then I thought that you know what I mean
once you do a crime you get out do the
time you know when you get your Johnny
job you won I was thinking that's stupid
but
if I thought that it affect me like this
I would have stopped immediately because
I'm going through hell man right now
trying to do something and and I don't
even feel like a man trying to nickel
and Diamond while my girl pulls most
most of the weight
that's kind of sad you know what I mean
I just
I don't know man I just try to
I [__] my way through it you know
what I mean and just try to do the same
thing but I'm just going through that
revolving door I keep going doing the
same [__] same [__] and it's all it's
doing is [__]
it's [__] me up
what's been your lowest point what's
been your lowest point
my lowest point
I think right now
because even when I first did this that
my first 10 years
that flew by like this
seriously because I was in there
honestly I was in there gang banging
I was running around I was having a
blast to be honest because because it
went by so quickly and I had a lot of
friends in there
and then my second time this time flew
by like this I ain't gonna lie to you
because if you know how to do time it
goes like this
and that's what
messed me up though is that I didn't
feel that sentence you know what I mean
but when I'm out here
the way people are the way
I feel like I'm alone man honestly and
the people that I hang around with
they're just
we're just friends for the moment but
you got to keep an eye on them so
they're really not your friend you know
what I mean they're trying to come up
there's an angle everybody's playing
down here
so in reality if I
I I'm I'm doing this all by myself and
it's [__] hard
I gotta think through this [__] by
myself I gotta figure it out by myself
with spending another 10 years in prison
be of relief
no I mean I don't want to go back but I
know that when I was there I was at
peace because everything was decided for
me I didn't have to do nothing I had a
great job in there I was lead painter
lead electrician
and the staff show me how to do
everything and I was making a lot of
money in there
but see they didn't judge you for your
past because everybody in there has a
past you know what I mean but now I'm
out here with
law-abiding citizens that you know you
got to do good get a job you know
develop a nice resume
and
but they judge you for your past when
they ask you you know have you ever been
arrested
and I could I can sit there and lie but
they're still gonna check you know what
I mean and when they check like I I
signed up for um Urban Alchemy
you know that work group
they hired me because I had a background
they said man you did 23 years we want
you we got a position a clean one one
you can sit on your ass and just earn
some money because you know you did a
lot of time I said okay boom then they
fired me the next week for having a
background
can you believe that [__]
that [__] blew my [__] mind
we did a background check I said I know
I told you I had a background I know but
you know
because of your background we have to
let you go
I was like aren't you [__] serious
my girl looks at that as you [__] it
up
I said how's that [__] it up you know I
mean she said you just don't want to
work
I don't know man give me good memories
of Europe
of your life
childhood anything
yeah when I was uh
before she started I mean
I had a lot of good memories with my mom
my sisters when
before my stepfather I mean my
stepfather wasn't always a dirt bag man
I mean he when when he was a Christian
when he never drank and everything like
that I mean he was
he made it up to being a pastor and
everything he was doing great man we
lived a happy life
we never needed anything
but once he started drinking
that all went to [__] man
it was like night and day with that
he turned into a monster man he said hit
my mother break glass plates on her face
I would run in I would get my ass kicked
and you and he's the type that he likes
to play mind War he'll tell you man go
pick him up go go give me the belt that
I like and you know what [__] belt I
like you bring me back that little small
belt I'm gonna beat you harder
so I would bring him back a big ass belt
like this he would tell me to get naked
and you know beat me like that
and my mom wouldn't do nothing
that's [__] up you know
that's what I lived on but I was even at
that age I was so hard-headed that he
would tell me I'm beating you because
you [__] doing this doing this and
doing that and when once he did that I
would do the same [__] thing
he said don't go outside you'll beat me
then I'll go outside
I don't know what the hell I mean I was
just
I'm still
trying to figure [__] out today
are you self-destructive
I see myself like sabotaging certain
little things and
I'm trying to like
and then if I if I look at the big
picture and try to
take myself out of that how would it be
and I still can't see
like if I stop doing drugs man I'm gonna
be
miserable to a certain degree you know
what I mean until I start getting back
on my feet but
and then I don't know how that's going
to change because me I mean my girl met
me when I was doing drugs
you know what I mean
she might not like me off for drugs
what's your biggest fear now
getting killed
well we end your life an overdose or
somebody's somebody killing me
over what
Benjamin I already heard there was a
couple things out there
it's over stupid [__] man it's over like
always a girl
a girl looked at me and some dudes his
little Mexican kid
think that I was trying to [__] his girl
and he put out a [__] and ever since
that that lasted to this day is still
going on I gotta stay away from certain
areas from 18th Street that's why I
don't never you never see me in
MacArthur Park ever
if I go through there I go through their
[__] fast as hell get on a bus get
the [__] out of Dodge
dear friends yeah I had one female
friend called rain
um
she does drugs too but she's always been
a stable
a friend whenever as I was down and out
she would always take me in if if I was
going through too much on the street
she'd just be like come in just stay
here for a [__] week man relax man
you know what I mean you don't have to
be out there every [__] day
and she's always been consistent man I
love her for that you know and um and a
few others like my boy Aaron he comes
down from Lancaster every week
he's cool and I can stay with him
anytime I want but I never
I don't like pushing myself on to other
people that that's that's his spot I
don't actually have my own [__] you know
I mean
I don't see it man you know that simple
question they ask you what do you see
yourself in five years
I don't see [__]
at all man
because every time I get something every
time something good happens
either I find a way to [__] it up or
or it [__] it up you know
George what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
learn
to listen to your instincts listen to
yourself because before I would I would
do what anybody told me to do you know
what I mean they told me go do this go
do that oh don't worry about this don't
worry don't do that because that's what
got me in prison so many times
just learn if I once I learned how to
listen to my intuitions this is the
longest I've ever eaten my my recidivism
rate
of coming back to prison was three
months once released the days they said
that I would return with the same crime
or even worse within three months
and I haven't been back for eight nine
years
so I proved them wrong you know what I
mean but I learned to listen to myself
when guys get too crazy out here like
about boost I do like soft [__] you know
what I mean like
but when I see guys like okay we're
gonna go do this like picking up a gun
or something like that I'm like okay I'm
out you guys handle that I'm not in for
that
what drugs are you using currently
currently I'm using crystal meth
Fentanyl
weed drinking
a little bit of everything
but I try not to overdo it because I
gotta say
level-headed so I don't want to be
dragging myself around you know I mean I
just want to feel nice and
go
like today I smoke the pipe like
three or four times
I hit the
with my Dabber I had fitting on like
maybe three times today
that's it you put it have you OD'd
ild once
when I first started doing fentanyl I
all deed in the bathroom and my girl
thought I was still taking a shower but
I actually fell out hit my head
I lay down the floor for like three
hours and she went to work she thought I
was still in the shower when I woke up I
had a big ass bump in my head and
everything
that was crazy
did you ever think your your life would
take this path
when you were a kid
not like this
this is crazy it's like I
it's like I hate myself sometimes come
too many for for me to do that to myself
it's hard to like
why would I you know I mean why would I
sabotage you man
it's like I hate myself I shouldn't be
doing that [__] but I I do it
all right George thank you so much for
sharing your story all right thank you
man I hope things change for you
thanks